Hey, this is a super interesting, a data point
in trying to figure out how the Youtube Algorithm
works.
Now I want to preface this by telling you
that youtube is deliberately and notoriously
opaque about how the algorithm works and supposedly
the reason for this is that they believe that
if people knew exactly how the Youtube Algorithm
works, they would be able to game the system
and unfairly take advantage of that algorithm
for personal gain.
But even if that's partially true, there are
all sorts of other reasons that youtube would
be incentivized to keep that algorithm a secret,
which includes that a secret algorithm better
enables them to manipulate or control the
specifics of the algorithm without having
to explain themselves.
Since much like, you know, religion and God
works in mysterious ways, the algorithm is
complex, it's always learning, it's always
being modified.
So one of the areas that's gotten a ton of
talk about Youtube Algorithm is about monetization.
Um, especially with the recent Steven Steven
Crowder, Carlos Mazda situation, the initial
non demonetization of Crowder's videos.
Then demonetization, then I believe re monetization
of Steven Crowder's content after this incident
where he was, uh, participating in gay bullying
effectively of Carlos Mazda.
The topic of what is considered monetized
able by youtube algorithm made a bunch of
headlines and a lot of articles were written
about it in the last few days.
Some youtube burrs, we'll try to avoid certain
trigger words that we think cause a video
to lose monetized status.
Other youtubers think that it really comes
down to the topic.
It's not so much about the video title itself.
Uh, there are debates about does the thumbnail
influence whether the youtube algorithm will
or won't monetize your videos.
Those are all sorts of the debates that exist
around monetization.
But there's a totally different conversation
about the algorithm, which is how does the
Youtube Recommendation Algorithm work?
This is the algorithm that determines which
other videos we'll youtube suggest to you
as you are watching videos on youtube website.
And this is tailored to each individual viewer
based on their watch history and other, uh,
elements, uh, which aren't totally clear to
us.
Again, because the algorithm is relatively
opaque.
So, for example, when I was logged into my
personal youtube account this morning, not
the show account, and I watched a video from
yesterday, uh, the algorithm suggested to
me a John Oliver Video, a good morning Britain
video about Trump, a CNN video from a congressional
hearing, CBS News Video about 2020 democratic
polling, a Bill Maher video from years ago
that infamous radical Islam video with Sam
Harris and Ben Affleck, uh, and then a video
from vice about black conservatives.
So an open question is how many of these recommendations
are based on what Youtube thinks I'm most
interested in?
How much of it is based on what is most profitable
for youtube to promote, which may not be the
same as what I'm most interested in.
And does youtube have a sort of black list
and white list white list, including channels
that youtube is going to disproportionately
promote merely because they've decided that
that's what they're going to do?
I don't know the answers to any of those questions,
but I have a really interesting data point
for you today and it has to do with my appearance
on Joe Rogan's program.
Last week, viewer Alexander wrote to me, take
a look at what he said.
Hey David, I just wanted to share an interesting
experience I've had with your channel after
watching you on Joe Rogan last night watching
today's show.
My recommended videos are entirely Joe Rogan.
Scrolling down, I count 10 Joe Rogan videos
all before any content I've watched recently.
I've only once viewed Joe Rogan's content
and that was last night.
Now my queue is full of his content.
I know you're always looking for insights
into the Youtube Algorithm and I thought I'd
share this with you and Alexander actually
sent me a screenshot of this and indeed while
watching our full show for members video from
yesterday, every single recommended video
was from the Joe Rogan experience.
Now this is fascinating because Alexander
says he has only watched one Joe Rogan video
in his life and it was the one I was on and
it was yesterday.
He presumably has years of youtube history
of watching all sorts of other things and
he watches one Joe Rogan video and suddenly
every recommendation, even when he goes back
to my videos is only Joe Rogan video.
So there's a few things that could be going
on here and there are more, which I encourage
you to write to me.
If you think of them.
Number one, youtube could have certain channels
that it promotes as soon as someone watches
even a single video because they are in some
sense playing favorites with certain channels.
Maybe Joe Rogan's channel is a youtube favorite
because uh, youtube finds it profitable.
Youtube finds that it increases watch time
drastically and keeps people on the website,
whatever the case may be.
It doesn't have to be nefarious reasons.
Another possibility is that Joe Rogan's content
is genuinely so engaging in a way that nothing
else is on youtube.
That the algorithm has determined that as
soon as anyone watches even one Joe Rogan
video, the algorithm should show them all
Rogan videos because that is going to lead
to really high engagement and it's going to
keep people on the website.
And it's not about playing favorites or a
white list of sorts, it's just that the content
is that engaging.
But something about this is more than random
chance or what we would call like typical
algorithmic behavior, watching youtube for
years and never Rogan.
You Watch one Rogan video and the next day,
every single video in the recommendations
feed is a Joe Rogan video.
I don't know what we learned from this, but
it's interesting and given the interest in
understanding Youtube's algorithm because
it's so opaque and because it really is an
important thing in determining how much creators
like us make.
Uh, I want to get your thoughts about this
and I want to really, I think Alexandra for
taking a screenshot of that and sending it
to me, let me talk about something that I'm
getting more and more emails about.